Malcolm In The Middle star Frankie
Muniz grew up in front of audiences,
from his hit show to his starring roles in
Agent Cody Banks and Big Fat Liar. He's kept
a low profile since, so here's what Muniz has been
up to since saying goodbye to playing Malcolm.
After the final episode of Malcolm
in the Middle aired in 2006,
fans were eager to find out what Muniz would
do next, but he needed a change of pace.
Even before going to Hollywood, Muniz
was active in theater, which was how
he eventually transitioned into appearing in
commercials and landing his first film roles.
Muniz had been playing Malcolm for six years, and
he was ready for some time away from the camera.
Muniz once said that by the time his
run as Malcolm was over, he had quote -
"done little else but work for 12 years."
That kind of schedule would be difficult
enough for an adult actor to handle,
let alone a child actor. He didn't leave
Hollywood altogether, but significantly
cut back on his schedule, mostly making
one-off appearances on TV shows or movies.
After shooting Agent Cody Banks 2 in 2004, Muniz
began to think about landing more mature roles,
but he admitted that dealing with
the transition was challenging.
In an interview with About, the actor commented
that he assumed that upon becoming a legal adult,
he'd begin getting more mature roles,
but that wasn't the case, saying -
"I haven't been scared but I've really been
thinking about it a lot, that I really have to
do something at this point right now to break the
mold […] I really need to do something different."
But Muniz struggled to navigate this phase
in his career, after becoming so well known
for his past characters that he wasn't taken
seriously in other roles. For instance, in 2007,
he switched gears with a role in the rom-com My
Sexiest Year, which received middling reviews,
and in 2008, he appeared in Extreme
Movie, which was panned by critics.
Eventually, Muniz decided to take up a new
passion that surprised some of his fans.
In 2001, he drove the pace car in the Toyota 500,
and in 2004, he won the Toyota Pro-Celebrity Race.
However, he knew that there was no way he'd be
able to balance both acting and racing. In 2006,
he decided to simply go on hiatus from
acting for a while, telling BBC News -
"I want to want to act and, right now, I want
to race. You can't really juggle both because,
if you do, you just don't
get enough time in the car."
This wasn't an impulsive decision on Muniz's
part. He spent plenty of time training to
get behind the wheel, and he impressed his
instructors. He competed with Jensen MotorSport,
and his solid performance
in pre-season testing earned
praise from team boss Eric Jensen.
Muniz raced for several years,
closing out his racing career with another showing
at the Toyota Pro-Celebrity Race in 2011.
While racing, Muniz got
into an accident and became
seriously injured, saying
on Dancing With the Stars -
"I had a crash and broke my back
and injured my hands and ribs."
It took him quite a while to recover, and he
still feels the effects of these injuries today.
He admitted that he and his dance partner,
Witney Carson, ended up talking about his
injuries all the time during rehearsals
because he felt like he had quote -
"the creaky, old body of a 71-year-old."
He didn't let his past injuries hold him back
from pursuing other exciting opportunities,
and he still considers himself
an active, athletic person.
At the age of seven, Muniz got his first
concussion while playing soccer, and since then,
he has suffered eight more. Later in life, he
began dealing with frightening mini-strokes.
In fact, Muniz says that he had visited
the emergency room on at least 15 different
occasions because of these adverse health
events. The fact that he survived his first
mini-stroke was nothing if not miraculous: He
realized that something was wrong while he was
riding his motorcycle, and while losing his
vision, he somehow made it home to his family.
"I kinda lost all peripheral vision,
and like started feeling like I was
losing my balance and uh, just started
feeling really really uncomfortable."
To this day, Muniz has no clear answers as
to why he has suffered from mini-strokes.
He's always been very focused on living a
healthy lifestyle, telling Entertainment Weekly -
"I'm 31, I've never sipped alcohol, I've never
touched a drug or taken a drag of a cigarette.
The only thing I've felt was stress.
I'm a high-strung person. I just like
to always be moving. I'm not good at relaxing."
For the most part, Muniz hasn't endured
long-term complications from experiencing
mini-strokes. But he has dealt with one
setback: memory loss. Muniz admits that today,
he doesn't remember much of his time
working on Malcolm in the Middle.
But Muniz says that for the most part,
his memory loss doesn't bother him.
Although dealing with these
health issues can be difficult,
he chooses to stay focused on the positives.
His wife, Paige Price, even helps him keep
track of things they've done together by writing
them down in a journal. As Muniz told People -
"I only know what it's like to be
me and if I don't let it bother me,
I just try to live the most
fulfilling, best life I can.
I really try to take advantage of my
time. And I've got a lot in my life."
Muniz has a wide variety of interests.
Ian addition to acting and racing,
he's also passionate about music. He
began playing the drums when he was 12,
and he always enjoyed it as a hobby and
a momentary reprieve from the spotlight.
"I'm the drummer you know,
no one looks at the drummer. You know
what I mean? You got the front man -"
"Sorry man, no-nobody,
nobody looks at the drummer."
"Sorry."
In 2012, Muniz decided to put his racing career
on hold in order to pursue music professionally.
He joined the band You Hang Up as a drummer
when they were unsigned. It all started with a
random message from Aaron Brown, the band's lead
vocalist and guitarist, as Muniz told PennLive -
"Aaron called and asked if I'd be interested
in jamming with them, since he knew I played
drums. I was like, 'I don't want to jam
with you guys, I want to be in the band!'"
Later, Muniz went on to play drums with the
band Kingsfoil and in 2017, he switched gears
and began managing the band Astro Lasso,
taking them on tour with We the Kings.
Although Muniz has taken long
stretches of time away from acting,
he never walked away from the industry. Throughout
the years since Malcolm in the Middle ended,
Muniz has occasionally done guest spots on TV
shows and appeared in supporting roles in movies.
Unfortunately for Muniz, most of his films
have not gotten glowing reviews. In 2016,
he appeared in the family flick Another Day
in Paradise, which told the story of two girls
helping their widowed father accept their mother's
death. In 2018, Muniz went in a new direction when
he starred in the horror film The Black String.
Interestingly enough, critics weren't crazy about
the film, but Muniz's performance did earn some
praise with critic Brittany Witherspoon writing -
"Elevating this script from a derivative
and simple one is no easy task,
but Muniz does it effortlessly."
Muniz moved to Arizona because he was ready to
get away from Los Angeles, telling PennLive -
"I always say moving out of LA and moving
to Phoenix, I feel, saved my life."
Later, Muniz settled down in
Scottsdale with his partner,
Paige Price, whom he married in 2019. The couple
loved the area's unique charm and Old West vibes.
However, he says that new developments
in the city have made him a bit concerned
for Scottsdale's future, lamenting
in an interview with AZ Central -
"It's becoming like a little bit of a mini LA.
Not that I want to get into an LA bash-fest,
but I moved here because I love what
it has here. [...] I hope it doesn't
grow too big where you lose some of that charm."
Muniz and Price bought Outrageous
Olive Oils & Vinegars in Scottsdale,
Arizona, and became small business owners.
"My fiance and I were looking
to do something together
and we found this little - this store and this
brand and we loved it and we took it over."
And Muniz didn't simply hire
people to run the store for him;
he took a very hands-on approach,
with the couple bottling,
labeling, and sealing everything themselves. As
he explained in an interview with AZ Central -
"It's a lot of work, but it's really rewarding
when people come in and rave about the product."
Muniz and Price were genuinely proud of the olive
oils and other products they put on the shelves,
before selling the shop in 2020.
In September 2020, Muniz and Price
excitedly announced that they were going to
become parents. The couple revealed to their
fans that they would be welcoming a baby boy into
their family. In the announcement Muniz said -
"While we still believe it's the little moments in
between the big ones that make you feel happiest,
nothing quite compares to hearing
your little one's heartbeat."
From that moment, Muniz's focus
in life completely shifted:
he immediately started suggesting baby names and
wondering what their child's future would be like.
The couple welcomed their son Mauz on March
22nd, 2021, and now it looks like Muniz
will be focused on spending lots of time
with his family and enjoying fatherhood.
Fans of Muniz will be happy to hear that
despite stepping away from Hollywood,
he has no intentions of retiring from
acting altogether. Early in 2021,
Muniz had a guest role as Corey Harris on the
comedic crime drama The Rookie. He's also set
to play a deputy in the Western film Hot Bath an'
a Stiff Drink 2, and has a role in Road to Capri,
a comedy film about two brothers who only discover
that they're related after their father's death.
While Muniz might never commit as
much time to acting as he once did,
he'll likely stick around in
Hollywood for years to come.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite child stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.